à
inconnu du grand public il y à peine un
an le pensionnats pour autochtones de
kamloops et aujourd'hui tristement
célèbre depuis que les dépouilles de 215
enfants y ont été découvertes l'endroit
est devenu synonyme d'un éveil brutal à
kamloops ou dans les autres
établissements un peu partout au canada
impossible désormais d'ignorer l'horreur
des pensionnats
[Musique]
l'ancien dortoir des garçons était gardé
intacte pour ne jamais oublier les
sévices et des tentatives d'assimilation
encore aujourd'hui plusieurs membres de
la communauté sont incapables d'y
remettre les pieds explique rose anne
casimir lors de son face à face avec le
pape la semaine prochaine la cheffe
pensera beaucoup à cette pièce
lorsqu'elle lui demandera formellement
de présenter des excuses
représentant de sa communauté mais aussi
les premières nations de colombie
britannique
rosen casimir se prépare depuis des mois
a rencontré le pape fille et
petite-fille de survivants deux semaines
pensionnat elle sait que l'audience
ravivera de profondes blessures
pour notre
l'archevêque dès maintenant et je
souhaitais cinq autres évêques
accompagneront la délégation
même si l'église catholique canadienne a
déjà présenté ses excuses l'an dernier
il reconnaît que celle attendue de la
part du pape revêt une importance
particulière à plusieurs reprises
j'entends de la part des peuples
indigènes le sentiment que j'ai besoin
d'apprendre les paroles am sorry je
m'excuse pour faire avancer mon propre
guérison en moi le chef de l'église
catholique saura trouver les bons mots
croît monseigneur smit il assure surtout
que le vatican veut jouer un rôle
s'insère dans la réconciliation
on va voir directement ce qui veut dire
la réconciliation en action
tendre la main en amitié
s'écouter décerné en semble marcher
ensemble
mais dans la communauté de techno petit
coin mec d'éventuelles excuses du pape
ne réjouissent pas tout le monde l'acte
de contrition arrive des décennies trop
tard selon l'ancien chef single free
tout juste arrivé à kamloops pour ses
études le jeune autochtone colisée que
y'a estime lui aussi qu l'église
catholique si trop longtemps traîné les
pieds avant de reconnaître ses torts
[Musique]
peut-être qu'une visite sur place du
pape rentrer ses excuses plus
convaincante à rome roseanne casimir
invitera formellement françois promis à
se rendre à kamloops elle souhaite que
les chefs d'églises catholiques visitent
le site on y trouvait les 215 dépouille
chef casimir voudrait aussi que le pape
puisse adresser l'ensemble des membres
de communautés mais surtout qu'ils
prennent le temps d entendre s'est
emporté
sur la santé
les découvertes faites ici ont provoqué
de grandes douleurs il ancien mouvement
sans précédent pour connaître toute la
vérité sur les anciens pensionnat des
plaies ont été rouvertes et rosanne
casimir souhaite maintenant commencer à
les soigner entre kamloops et rome le
chemin vers la guérison sera long et
sinueux mais elle y croit
[Musique]